and I'm in the middle of watching the
World Series and out of nowhere they
have this moment stand up to cancer I'm
watching a ball game and all of a sudden
everybody stands up no there's a time
and a place look I know somebody
let me know somebody that has died of
cancer I would never go to the movies
with you and in the middle of it hit
pause and be like oh by the way Conan
I love all the USC female Fighters
that's why I want my daughter to know
how to know all of that stuff that'd be
cool when she meets a creep like you she
could choke you up
I would say 13 of people on the internet
are cool the rest of them they're
they're just a bunch of animals why
would you want to why would you want to
talk to them wait you're saying only 13
percent of people
13 are cool the other 87 percent are
right and horrific stuff under YouTube
videos they're they're they're [ __ ]
yeah
the deepest couch in sports
entertainment a lot of people think that
uh they're uncomfortable with my uh my
um elevation are you uncomfortable with
it no I just see all of your
insecurities
that's going around saying that 87
percent of the world sucks you're not
going to get well this is the thing
you're not gonna I can't say that
because there's nothing you can take
away from me what are you gonna do
you're going to say I can't do stand-up
and strip malls anymore that's usually
especially the punishment so the genius
I felt My Religion made sense in
everybody else's sound is stupid
I did
look I'm not talking about the basis of
every religion basis of every religion
makes sense you know the Ten
Commandments right don't kill anybody
they'll touch my wife that's my bike
right
thank you
that all makes sense
of which I've broken I think I've broken
spot every commandment except for the
fifth one that's it
I haven't killed anybody yet all right
but the murderous thoughts that I have
sometimes I I think I could do it
like when someone gets on a plane and
they kick off their loafers and they're
wearing those gold toed like dress socks
they cross their feet at the ankles and
they just start rubbing their feet
together
like I see the whole thing see the whole
thing
wrapping that
it's worse than that for people
everyone's got an iPhone you know hey
look I can't say that I'll just say he's
gone they still came out with another
one right
[Applause]
Van Halen could Eddie not play guitar
anymore you know what I'm saying right
that's a good analogy it have a
superpower what would it be
Ah that's a good one
you know what it would be
when I'm when I'm second in line to make
a left
and the person doesn't pull up to get
out in the intersection and make sure I
make it my superpower will be that I
could mentally move them out into the
intersection
and if they gave me the finger I would
slowly slide them into oncoming traffic
I would I wouldn't make them hit
because that's an innocent person over
there
is like uh Marvel characters your [ __ ]
is like a villain I'm lying to you
everybody's pretending that they care
they don't if you really listen to
people what they care about is what
affects them true nobody gives a [ __ ]
about the eight-year-old who made this
jacket do I do I write him and say thank
you for sewing this together what makes
you feel old about watching TV
ah this well music there's no guitar
solos anymore and then for some reason
with all this technology Millennials if
you take a full water bottle and you
flip it in the air and it lands upright
they run out of the room like they just
saw a witch
but what did you say about the military
that got people so mad or this one guys
I was just saying like yeah the guy who
flies the fighter jet okay and has
missile shot and that guy's a hero
however if you're the guy that like
points in the direction that the plane
takes off and
she does the most difficult job on the
planet she's the mother
so immediately I look at my girlfriend
I'm like really
being a mom is the most difficult job on
the planet
how many mothers died on Ice Road
Truckers last season
catching that lobster trap to the back
of your head
you'd send them to bed anytime you
wanted some trumped-up charges
because you want to have a drink and
watch the prices right
evidently these mothers they're bending
over at the waist putting DVDs into DVD
players
you have a burp a baby and forget to put
that towel up there there's another
shirt you gotta wash oh lift with your
knee
and put it in that machine that does it
for you
Dude any job you can do in your pajamas
is not difficult
so you got to figure out a way to like
thin out the herd and it's too late
decisions that are going to have to be
made we are we're here to hear about
some bad choices so you know how I would
do it what I would I would randomly sink
cruise ships